his work changed our view of the world
and turned conventional thinking on its
head gant benek helped open up the
incredibly tiny universe of atoms and
molecules at first no one believed it
would ever be possible to make
individual atoms visible but then a new
method developed by Vinick straddled the
border between physics and chemistry
subway can you clean chemistry is all
the rage nowadays everyone wants that no
toxins that's the direction the
chemistry is headed in argument the
important thing is to observe chemical
processes so as to better understand
what's actually going on so you can then
make the right decisions I'm you lifting
each item to put this is the instrument
Finnegan his colleague hi Nicola
developed in the early 1980s the
scanning tunneling microscope its secret
is an exceedingly thin tip just one atom
wide that scans the surface of a sample
detecting the contours of each
individual atom leave me to my last
mommy saw atoms for the first time with
the microscope it was an overwhelming
moment I realized it was something
completely different the beginning of a
whole new era for physicists for
humankind and also for myself if you
think every major I knew I would never
experienced a moment like that again at
least as far as science was concerned it
was a breakthrough isn't just underlined
Navidi fantasies that's wonderful but
soon the new technology was not just
about imaging the atoms before long the
researchers were also able to use the
force of the tip as a tool to manipulate
them shifting them around and even
lifting them up
he knocked in David night we saw Adams
for the first time I was alone in the
lab and I was the first to play around
with them I tried to manipulate them
right from the start a man fire that
pioneering work has enabled chemists to
develop materials with entirely new
properties like materials that are
scratch resistant that propelled dirt or
that act as flame retardance it was all
made possible by the researchers foray
into the Nano cosmas of atoms and
molecules samimi it's all about
molecules that do something with each
other nanoparticles these tiny particles
that interact with one another actually
to be accurate chemistry is
nanotechnology when he started his work
binning had little idea what the world
of nanoparticles would look like and
whether the team would ever reach it but
their creativity and perseverance were
crowned by success and the Nobel Prize